it emerges from a Labyrinth of mangroves
on Mexico's Pacific Coast
the tiny island of Mescal Titan we've
come here to see if the legend is true
if this is the long-lost home of
Mexico's Aztecs
The Story Goes that they travel from an
island called Aslan to what's now Mexico
City where they founded their empire
locals believe that Mescal Titan is the
Aslan of the past the key evidence the
form of the island itself
you'll find the same shape the island
has later in Mexico City in what was
then tenosh decline it was identical and
it was in the middle of a lake too just
like yeah
here it is the distinctive circular
shape of Mescal Titan with its roads
pointing to the four cardinal points
like a great Shield
strikingly similar to here Mexico City
in the late 2 in its 15th century
aztecade more proof a stone found close
to the island with a snake in a Heron's
mouth this one's a replica
similar to the snake in an eagle's mouth
which became the symbol of the Aztecs in
Mexico City
a poor fishing island is trying to
Parlay its assumed history into tourism
money Nacho's here with his nieces and
nephews some of them from the US Mexico
I wanted them to know the story of
Mexico that basically starts here
their Roots the start of it all because
they call this place the Cradle of
Mexico but there is polemic around the
Island's claim every school kid in
Mexico learns the legend of the Aztecs
their long pilgrimage to Mexico City
their starting point on the coast but
could it really be here that it all
kicked off is there enough evidence
back on the mainland archaeologist Jose
Beltran tells us that this could be one
of the origin places of the Aztecs but
not the only one
it's a symbol of a great Regional
migration it could have been a center
but it's not more than a symbol
so there's no definitive proof Miss
galtitan is the Cradle of the Aztecs but
without stories what are we
and this island is clinging to this one
John Holman Al Jazeera Mescal Titan